[Music]
big night for Julian Edelman he became
the Super Bowl MVP and in 17 postseason
games in his career he's got a hundred
and fifteen receptions second only to
Jerry Rice's 151 1412 receiving yards
that's also second all-time and he's
tied for 26th with six receiving
touchdowns and what happened last night
I saw people begin to say it and it kind
of bubbled up even before last night the
idea that Julian Edelman may be laying
the foundation for a Hall of Fame career
look Chris when you look at everything
he's accomplished or not accomplished
the numbers aren't there the
accomplishments aren't there there
aren't enough spots available in Canton
to give him the Julian element just
because he won a Super Bowl MVP award I
mean mark Griffin Larry Brown right
there have been plenty of guys who have
become the Super Bowl MVP no business
ever whisper phil simms that have no
business ever whispering the kanten you
said it not me but but that doesn't I
mean look that's one piece right there
are so many other pieces that have to go
into it before you get into can well I'm
so glad to hear you say that because I
thought you were gonna be a prisoner of
the moment and then start telling me
that you know again Julian Edelman for
me all-time legend NFL legend certainly
you know yeah you're going to have to
bring up Julian Edelman name or a few
plays that he's made when you tell the
story of the NFL whether it be some of
those great catches in the Seahawks or
the Falcons game that were just out of
this world but not a hall-of-famer no
there's nothing in his career that says
Hall of Fame I mean you know no Pro
Bowls
no no all-pro teams only two thousand
yard seasons right I mean he's hundred
and forty eighth on most catches ever
248 on most receiving yards all-time
Hall of Fame receivers are guys you can
line up in one spot and say hey we're
gonna put you here and we think you can
beat the best corner on the other team
all game long consistently or if not
they're gonna double cover you and it's
gonna open up everything else Edelman is
awesome don't get me wrong but he is a
product of that system and he's a
perfect piece for that system in New
England so
awesome legend but no not a hall-of-fame
for my money Hey look another fair point
we talked about this earlier in the
program as it relates to his his overall
legacy his status in the NFL
how many Hall of Famers have been
suspended for peds I think that's I
don't know my head yeah it hurts that
that day went when we're listing the
pros and the cons right that that is one
of the things that would go against
Julian Edelman ever even getting to the
point where he'd be one of the 15
finalists no question for me I'm never I
mean listen I don't like that
yeah it really troubles me and when
anybody has that you know notch on their
resume that they've been tested positive
for performance-enhancing drugs yeah it
makes me wonder and I don't mean to go
personal on Julian Edelman here but
these are the facts of the situation and
he put himself in this situation for us
to have this conversation you're right
right I know you're right when is when
his explanation is I don't know what
happened thank you that's the best
you've got yes I don't know what
happened y know what happened yeah there
was a cup right Pete in it they tested
it they found peds right that's what
happened that's right that's right thank
you you're right I was B I was I was
being a wimp there thank you for making
me cross the line with some fury but
exactly right I mean but it's up bothers
but it's not there's nothing wrong no
wrong what's right there's nothing wrong
saying I know I guess I feel a little
guilty the day after the guys winning
the MVP and he's having a great day and
I'm trying to rain on his parade so as a
human I feel a little guilty but you're
right he put himself in that situation
and put us in this situation to talk
about it but again yes that's a that's a
thing that would bother me for the Hall
of Fame he's a legend he's going to be
in the Patriots Hall of Fame and do all
those great things and statistically
gonna be one of the greatest you know
playoff wide receivers ever but I don't
necessarily sit there and go oh you know
all these stats are just because Edelman
is amazing and he can beat everybody in
coverage and he's just a one-on-one
matchup nightmare no he's a nightmare
because he has a certain skillset that
the New England Patriots know how to
utilize within their complex system and
always put him in a spot where
he can be successful like we saw last
night how many times was he one-on-one
with the middle linebacker in the middle
of the field to catch the ball middle
linebacker shouldn't be having to cover
Julian Edelman one-on-one in the middle
of the field but the Patriots found a
way to say oh well we have a few ways to
get him and match up against your
defense and of course as I'm saying that
he's beating Marcus Peters but
regardless he's in the slot making those
plays out but here you go here's a
linebacker trying to cover him there you
go that was my point if you're watching
a TV but nope nobody could cover him
last night
and I'm surprised the Rams didn't
consistently double cover him and look
it's a great game it's a great
performance but you're right if it's not
him it's somebody else in that spot and
and I don't want to take anything away
from what he did I don't want to rain on
his parade like you said but he ran it
on his own parade when he sprinkled
dirty urine into that cup whenever it
was that he triggered the positive test
that got him suspended for the first
four games of this season yes this is
fresh this isn't some we're digging up
from five years ago
it's part of who he is as a player it's
part of what he's done and it's part of
what would be considered yet have to
consider that as part of the broader
case for induction into the Hall of Fame
and I don't know the answer the question
or are there other Hall of Famers then
tested positive for Bede know the answer
that question I don't think there's a
whole lot I feel like you know hey
certainly some probably sneaked through
the cracks in the 60s 70s 80s or
whatever it may be but I can't remember
anybody off the top of my head at this
point right now where I go oh yeah pe D
suspension and Hall of Fame no it's
certainly gonna hurt his resume when
that conversation does come up but
regardless I don't even think without
that I don't think he's a Hall of Fame
player like I said awesome football
player legend but not in the class of
you know other Hall of Fame receivers
and their talents and what they could
bring to a team and the mismatch that a
hall-of-famer could bring at the wide
receiver position credit where credit's
do though he has been a huge part of
this second half of the Patriots dynasty
the three Super Bowls they run 49 51 53
he was huge in all those remember in 39
the question was did he have
concussion and was he properly evaluated
51 he had that catch where the ball was
like on the ground I somehow kept his
hands underneath he's been a big
contributor in those games it's not
enough to get you into the Hall of Fame
although some would say some would say
it was enough to get Lynn Swann in right
different era different time yeah
receivers weren't generating the kind of
statistic even given what we're doing
now Edelman's not getting the kind of
numbers that I think you need to get in
no I don't think so be there hey he's
tough he's clutch he run blocks he
catches the ball over the middle he's
got fire he's a leader all of those
things are great and he's awesome and I
respect him for that but I don't see a
Hall of Fame you know it busting camp at
anytime soon
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports